a candy machine creates small chocolate
wafers in the shape of circular disks
the diameter of each wafer is 16
millimeters what is the area of each
candy of each wafer I'm guessing so
that's a wafer the diameter is 16 so
this is the center the diameter is 16
millimeters and they want us to figure
out the area so that's so that's equal
to the diameter so the area and so the
the formula that one of the famous
formulas of geometry for the area of a
circle is PI R squared where pi is
3.14159 on and on and on the ratio of
the circumference to the diameter of a
circle R is the radius of the circle so
they told us the diameter of a circle
and the radius is just half of that
because the radius is half of a diameter
so the radius for this circle for each
of these wafers is going to be 8
millimeters so the radius that part
right there is going to be 8 millimeters
so the area of our circle is going to be
equal to pi times 8 millimeters squared
and I'll keep the unit's there just so
that we get the right units for area at
the end so area is going to be equal to
PI times 64 meters squared or I guess
you could call them square meters or
just to write this the way it's
typically written area is equal to 64 pi
meters squared now it's important to
realize pi is not a variable
it literally is representing just a very
famous number in mathematics pi is equal
to 3.14159 keeps going on and on without
repeating so we literally could take
3.14159 and put it in the place of pi
right over here and I'll use a and
sometimes people will approximate it
with 3.14 but I'll just go we'll use the
calculator to get the exact value so we
could say 64
you could just say 64 if you wanted a
very rough one you could say 64 times
3.14 which would give you 200 point nine
six millimeter squared but if you wanted
a more exact answer you could literally
go off and multiply 64 times pi
and I'm sure this calculator has PI
stored and ended up to some pretty
pretty accurate precision so 64 some
pretty precise precision I should say so
64 times pi exactly is 201 point zero
six so I'm gonna go with this because
this is the more precise answer 201
points nm and - the more accurate answer
201 point zero six so this is 200 one
point zero six square square millimeters